half of Americans believe in conspiracy
theories I love this story recent
studies suggest that around 50% of
Americans subscribed to at least one
conspiracy theory this info is coming
from NPR's social science correspondent
Shankar Van Daan Tam did I pronounce
that right you guys are definitely NPR
people no I think I think I was closed
from NPR's Morning Edition let's look at
the findings of the study so 19 percent
of Americans believe the US government
was behind the 9/11 attacks that seems
incredibly high to me so we'll get back
to that in a sec 25 percent believe the
recent financial crisis was caused by a
small cabal of Wall Street bankers and
here's a good one 11 percent believe the
government is mandating a switch to
compact fluorescent light bulbs because
the light bulbs make people obedient and
easy to control now I will play the
rational person here for one second Carl
Sagan said that extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence that's
generally how I think about these things
although I put they I have no problem
with aliens and pretty sure aliens have
been here and are manipulating us the 19
percent on 9/11 seems really high to me
what do you think although I know about
YouTube commenters that's probably very
low we do mean yeah and do I believe in
that number or do I think that it just
seemed high that one out of five
Americans would would believe that it
was like when you think about it
rationally but it actually seems low and
you think that you know in a moment of
sheer panic and helplessness you know in
times like that the part of our brain
the amygdala that's the fear center goes
into or it sends our brain into
analytical overdrive and it leads to us
sort of coming up with these narratives
that help us better explain these
circumstances which is is so out of the
ordinary and so you know so fearful and
yeah in a way in a country where this
many people believe what they hear on
Fox News nothing surprising frankly so I
mean think about conspiracy theories is
that I you know it's not like the
government is so pure that we can't ever
believe that any of them you know they
we didn't put smallpox in blankets and
give it to the Native Americans I mean
it's not like we're the US government is
incapable of shenanigans so it's not
the hardest thing to believe that
shenanigans are happening and no matter
the junk food holy shenanigans
I mean we do subsidize a lot of the
products that are making people you know
obese in this country and so you know
it's corn corn corn that's why the
government once makes it is making it
difficult for you know Tesla to sell
cars because the oil companies are
paying them to do it you know so why not
then think that maybe the CIA decided to
kill John F Kennedy or something I mean
you know okay so let's talk about the
fluorescent light bulb thing because I
think that one's amazing so eleven
percent are saying that these new
government mandated light bulbs the
light is actually a way of controlling
you what do you think fluorescent lights
in my high school and nobody was being
controlled so I'm not buying that one
not that that to me seems like a
fluoride in the water kind of right you
know john birch sort of wackiness I
don't know the fluorescent I don't know
I mean III can only you know tell you
know of my personal experience under
fluorescent lights I've always felt like
a little more anxious really yeah really
yeah they look weird they're not
flattering those fluorescent interesting
so by feel weird what do you mean by
that well I just you know it's it's the
lighting is never good it's never you
know comfortable you know as a kid I
never really liked being under that sort
of false life there's also an audible
component to it fluorescent lights and I
don't know yeah have like a home that I
think sets people off it's like tape
hiss almost you know it's got this like
really sort of you know subtle effect
and your subconscious but I don't know I
mean it's it's a pretty crazy idea that
the government will be trying to is that
the beauty of conspiracy theories you
don't have to prove any of them so it's
like yeah it's what's fun to believe in
something stuff like the alien stuff
obviously I have no proof but it also it
also feels good to think that you're you
know in a pack of sheep that you're the
wolf that has the idea you're not being
fooled
yeah do you guys have one that you
subscribe to I guess maybe the JFK thing
for you know the CIA I feel like there's
more to the JFK thing than we're being
told but I don't know what it is I
haven't done the research listen I saw
the Oliver Stone movie many times I did
down what do you think I'm not into
conspiracy theories nah not really
not my thing nothing no all right but we
know for a fact that Bush wanted to
invade Iraq the second he entered office
and that's actually like that's not
that's not even considered that's a
thing that we know now so that's well
that's the kind of thing that makes
conspiracy theories believable look at
us ending a conspiracy theory segment
with a fact that is some of it